[Musique]
la présidentielle française approche des
acteurs vont chercher ils cherchent déjà
influencer l'opinion sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis la France comme
l'étranger alors quelles opérations
peuvent être menées par des pays comme
la Russie par exemple dans le contexte
de la guerre en Ukraine pour savoir
quels sont les techniques les plus
courantes nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de David chavalarias il est
chercheur et directeur de l'Institut des
systèmes complexes à Paris avec son
équipe il scrute depuis 2017 des
centaines de millions de tweets lors de
la dernière élection présidentielle donc
nous avons développé un outil qui
s'appelle politoscope qui est un
observatoire en fait de la truite aux
sphère politique et nous avons pu
observer plusieurs actions qui ont visé
donc à déstabiliser l'élection ou
influencer le choix des électeurs une
première action consistait à reprendre
et amplifier les discours
Macron anti-mélochon pour favoriser
principalement l'extrême droite cette
action a été menée en partie par des
acteurs qui étaient à l'étranger
notamment les supporters de Trump aux
États-Unis et puis il y a eu aussi un
autre type d'action qui a consisté à
divulguer comme d'ailleurs ça s'est fait
également aux États-Unis avec Hillary
Clinton à divulgué des mails de en
marche c'est ce qu'on appelait les
Macron x juste avant le scrutin de
manière à faire croire qu'il y avait des
documents compromettants et que donc il
ne fallait pas porter la confiance à
Macron la période actuelle est très
sensible parce que déjà en 2017 la
Russie avait agi donc notamment via les
Macron X et les informations de
manipulation d'opinion dont je viens de
parler
lorsqu'il y a un affrontement entre un
pays et d'autres nations et c'est le cas
évidemment d'une part avec le conflit
Russo ukrainien évidemment le terrain
informationnel est un théâtre
d'affrontement qu'il faut
particulièrement surveiller ces
opérations avant parfois difficiles à
repérer Nicolas Arpajon expert en
cybersécurité nous explique pourquoi
souvent ce sont des actions qui sont
conduites sur la durée c'est-à-dire que
des faux profils vont être créés sur les
réseaux sociaux et pour leur donner de
la consistance de la crédibilité on va
commencer à les faire s'exprimer sur
plusieurs sujets ils vont interagir
entre eux ils vont se recommander entre
eux ils vont être présents sur
différentes plateformes dont vous aurez
par exemple un étudiant un universitaire
un cadre de banque qui aura un profil
Linkedin également prendra position sur
Twitter sera membre de telle association
d'anciens élèves interagira avec tel
autre profil les opérations frauduleuses
sur le terrain de la formation ne
demande pas de moyens financiers
importants elle demande de l'imagination
de la créativité et du temps par contre
c'est évident que au fur et à mesure on
va voir des outils d'intelligence
artificielle de machines learning qui
vont venir se substituer et qui vont
automatiser d'une part la création des
profils et l'animation de ceci il faut
reconnaître que la Russie a un
savoir-faire dans la manipulation de
l'information et à justement une
capacité d'action dans ce domaine c'est
la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs un
état comme la France c'est doté d'une
structure vigime son rôle c'est
précisément d'étudier les mouvements
informationnels de faire le tri entre ce
qui est l'expression bienvenue dans un
débat démocratique des opinions
divergentes et ce qui peut constituer
des actions concertées malveillantes ou
en tout cas initié par des intérêts
politiques extérieurs des entités à
l'étranger interviennent sur les réseaux
sociaux afin de diriger l'opinion
publique dans leur sens mais des
communautés politiques en France elles
aussi ont bien compris les rouages qui
permettent d'amplifier leur discours
l'une des techniques les plus utilisées
et l'astro turfing cela consiste à faire
croire à un élan spontané alors qu'en
réalité il s'agit d'un mouvement bien
coordonné ici ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a regardé donc fin 2021 quels
étaient les comptes qui avaient fait la
pratique qui consiste à reposter au même
moment le même message mais par
plusieurs comptes différents pour faire
croire que ce message là est défendu par
plusieurs personnes au même moment il y
a plusieurs comptes qui ressortent et là
la taille des comptes correspond au
nombre de fois ils ont fait cette
pratique d'astrotterfing donc les plus
gros ici on fait jusqu'à 1300 campagnes
d'astrotterfing donc ce que l'on voit là
c'est que cette communauté là qui en
fait la communauté autour d'Éric Zemmour
ont vraiment industrialiser ça
plus la date du scrutin approche plus
les opérations de manipulation se feront
virulentes alors comment les contrer au
fond ce qui fait le succès au nom de ses
campagnes c'est aussi et surtout la
capacité des utilisateurs à les déceler
pour ne pas se faire avoir mais je n'en
dis pas plus car ce sera l'objet du
deuxième épisode de cette série avoir
très bientôt sur France 24